foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear we're talking about an absolute
Classic on today's show the 1955 horror
Thriller known as diabolique now it's
actually only known as diabolique in the
U.S everywhere else in the world as far
as I'm aware it's known as Lei de I
believe uh you know plural and uh so
that actually translates as the Devils
or the fiends something like that and if
this is one of those movies where I kind
of feel like if you're a horror fan at
all like any kind of serious horror fan
you should see it at least once uh
preferably twice I'm gonna say because I
think kind of the famous twist at the
end of the story uh it's one of those
things that it re-contextualizes like
everything that you saw like up to that
point so it's like really instructive to
watch it a second time after you know
what the twist is so you can kind of
like see all the seeds that were planted
and stuff like that it's really neat to
do that now this movie
was actually sort of loosely based on a
1952 novel called she who was no more
and this was written by a writing team
who did a lot of suspense novels named
Pierre bollo and Thomas narkajak I think
is how you pronounce this that's
actually a pen name that's not his real
name but that's the name that he wrote
Under
um now what happened with this novel was
that the novel came out and Alfred
Hitchcock actually wanted to buy the
rights to it but before he could do that
like at a last minute thing the rights
were actually preemptively snapped up by
the French director producer uh Henry
George cluzo now he wanted to make this
movie as a vehicle for his actress wife
veracuzzo now this movie actually turned
out as I said this is a classic it's a
suspense classic if you haven't seen it
this is definitely one of the ones that
you need to see and it's so in film
circles it's just it seems like it's so
tremendously admired that it's been re
remade like a whole bunch of times there
was a 1974 TV movie
that's an adaptation of it that's called
reflections of murder there was a 1993
tv movie that's uh called House of
Secrets that was also an adaptation of
the same story and it also got like a
big budget kind of Hollywood remake in
1996 with uh Sharon Stone and Isabella
Johnny and Chaz Palminteri was in it too
and I think also Kathy Bates was in it
too and not only that so not only has
the story been remade multiple times but
the the way the story is like the plot
points and stuff have been homage in
like several other films like death trap
and stuff like that and like some other
TV episodes like Twilight Zone and
whatnot matter of fact Robert block the
guy that wrote the novel that psycho was
based on uh actually named diabolique as
his favorite horror film of all time and
it has actually been speculated I don't
know if this is true or not but this is
kind of How The Story Goes that Alfred
Hitchcock failing to get the rights to
this book like to make this movie in the
1950s actually directly led to him
opting to do an adaptation of Robert
Block's psycho instead and then the rest
was history now in its execution uh
diabolique is it does have a very
hitchcocky and vibe to it but that
shouldn't be a surprise because the
original book's authors were big
Hitchcock fans and I think that they
wrote the novel specifically in the
hopes that he would buy the rights and
adapt it now incidentally Alfred
Hitchcock even though he didn't do this
one obviously he did actually end up
adapting one of their novels later on
because their book from among the dead
was actually turned into his 1958 movie
vertigo so there you go with that but I
have to say that the director of this
movie on resource cluzo he brings his
own sensibility to uh diabolique and
it's just kind of like this very Bleak
very haunting story and it's kind of
like a classic suspense plot where like
the perfect murder but like on horribly
awry you know what I mean so veracuzzo
she's kind of the main character and she
plays uh Madame Christina DeLaSalle and
she's very very wealthy you're led to
assume that she's from like a wealthy
family or whatever but she's a very very
physically delicate woman she's
originally from Venezuela and she owns
this kind of somewhat run-down kind of
second-rate boys boarding school just
outside of Paris now she also has this
[ __ ] bag of a husband named Michelle
who's played by uh Paul Maurice and he
kind of acts as the school's principal
everybody at the school staff and
children alike are justifiably terrified
of him because he's just this very cruel
authoritarian [ __ ] you know he seems
like power mad type of thing and he's
just like cruel for no reason just
because he can be and he treats the kids
there and the staff like as badly as he
treats his wife like he's just a real
[ __ ] dick hole to her like at all
times now the wife also she has like a
heart condition like uh so she's like I
said very physically delicate and he's
constantly like mocking her being like
yeah I wish he'd hurry up and die blah
blah like all that kind of crap so you
know he's he's a real peach now also
suffering alongside Christina DeLaSalle
is another woman named Nicole ornay now
she's actually played by Simone senorae
and she is a teacher at the school also
she's like the math and science teacher
and she's also Michelle's mistress now
Nicole uh has been on the wrong end of
Michelle fists many times it would seem
and although it's implied that the two
women were enemies at first as would be
expected like given the circumstances
because one was like [ __ ] around on
you know on the wife or whatever uh but
after they kind of like met and hung out
they've subsequently bonded over their
Mutual hatred of this [ __ ] uh
now it should be noted too that like all
of their dirty laundry pretty much I
mean this is like not a big School uh
this whole sorted affair with like him
having the mistress and him being
abusive and all this other kind of stuff
is kind of like an Open Secret around
the school like everybody seems to know
like yeah he's knocking down that woman
and also he's like punching the [ __ ] out
of her and stuff like that so everybody
knows like what's going on but no one
really does anything about it you know
what I mean it's that kind of situation
so Nicole the mistress who seems like a
lot more she's very kind of like severe
she's very no-nonsense
um and she has come up with a plan to do
away with Michelle for good and if
everything goes as intended like as she
planned then his death will look like an
accident
now what she has kind of imagined she
needs Christina on board for this whole
scheme to work however Christina at
first does not really want to get
involved I mean she's kind of like mousy
and cowed she's not physically like
really up to it because she's like I
said her health is very very like
physically fragile and she's also like
really really religious like she's
really Catholic so she thinks that you
know anything that they do like that is
going to be a sin and that she's going
to hell like she really does actually
believe that so she's very reluctant to
go along with this even though uh she
does despise Michelle and wish he would
like just drop dead already however
after he essentially tells her like
right to her face that it's like hey
I'll be glad when you drop dead and I
can have all your money like you know I
can take over the school and like take
all your money uh she pretty much like
changes her tune and she's like uh yeah
so now she not only wants to off the
[ __ ] but uh she's like yeah I just
regret that he won't be alive to like
know that I'm the one that did it you
know what I mean so the primary stages
of the mission go pretty much as planned
Christina Nicole they go to Nicole's
place like she owns this she lives in
her apartment then she like rents out
like the top floor or whatever like and
it's a few I don't even remember I think
he said it took like 10 or 12 hours like
drive so it's like pretty far away so
they go there like and stay with Nicole
like over the holidays there's some like
holidays coming up I don't think it's
Christmas or anything but it's like some
School holiday like spring break or some
[ __ ] so they go there for a few days and
then Christina calls Michelle her
husband and essentially like lures him
there by saying hey guess what I'm
filing for divorce and I'm gonna sell
the school which means he's not gonna
have any money or job or anything like
that uh you know hence forward
now just as the women predicted he would
do
Michelle uh you know is like I'm coming
down there but he sneaks out of the
school like in order to catch the train
and get there because he has this
massive massive ego and he doesn't want
anybody at the school like the staff
like to see him leaving the school and
quote unquote running after a woman like
that would look really bad like if he
did that so and they're you know like I
said they know him so they know that
that's exactly what he would do and
that's what they wanted him to do
because they didn't want anybody to see
him leave or know where he went to so
once he gets to the town where Nicole
lives like on the train
the women drug him with alcohol like
they buy some kind of nice booze and
they lace it with this untraceable
sedative so they you know they roof am
essentially they make him go to sleep
and then they carry him into the
bathroom and drown him in the bathtub
so the next morning they actually load
his carcass into this big wicker basket
that they brought along that they said
had a bunch of dishes in it and then
they drive it back to the school and
they get there like in the middle of the
night because like I said it's like an
all-day drive you know from at that
point they kind of take the basket out
to the pool out back and they dump his
body in the school's gross ass swimming
pool which is just filled with this
filthy black water like I said it's kind
of like a second-rate boys school like
this doesn't look like it's very well
maintained or cleaned or anything so the
pool is just like full of this gross
like yucky black water so they dump it
in there they're kind of hoping that
when the corpse inevitably Rises to the
surface uh the staff will just assume
that Michelle just got you know
shit-faced drunk one night and then
wandered and fell into the pool and
drowned and it was an accident so this
seems like a foolproof plan for sure and
like I said everything is kind of just
going according like it's supposed to
but there's one little snag several days
go by and the body never surfaces
Christina who is already quite fragile
and is now like pretty racked with guilt
that they've actually done the thing is
really like having a hard time like
she's jumping at Shadows she's acted
like all sketchy and Nicole is like
afraid that she's just gonna crack up
and blow the whole deal and like tell
somebody just because she feels so
guilty and so freaked out so the women
can't really set their minds at ease by
having the pool drained because just
asking about it hey might want to have
that pool drained and see what's going
on with that you know what I mean that
would be like super super suspicious
like they knew something so they have to
kind of use these real roundabout means
to get the job done it's like oh look
I'm throwing some of my keys and oops I
dropped my keys into the pool kind of
thing like maybe we should drain it so I
can get my keys back just to put their
minds at rest like somebody needs to
find this [ __ ] body right so they do
that and then the pool gets drained like
the maintenance guy drains the pool but
they find to their surprise that
Michelle's body body has somehow done a
runner and is no longer in the pool
where they're pretty sure they dumped it
not only that but the suit that he died
in like that he was wearing when they
killed him is actually like the dry
cleaner like brings it back to the
school the next day like hey here's that
suit like that so and so dropped off or
whatever and uh they're just like what
the [ __ ] you know what I mean and also
one of the students like one of the boys
claims that he saw Michelle like the
principal that same day and he's like
yeah he yelled at me and like took my
slingshot because I broke a window
um and they're like yeah but he's
missing like he's not here and the weird
thing is like the staff they know that
he wanders off and he's like out like
hitting all the ladies you know what I
mean so they're just like they don't
think it's that weird that he hasn't
showed up for several days and like I
said it's been kind of like a vacation
too so they're not really all that
worried about it but yeah this kid was
like I know I saw him and they you know
put him in the corner for lying and all
that other kind of [ __ ] there's also the
small matter of they take like the
photographer and does like a faculty and
student group photo that may or may not
have like a weird ghostly blurry kind of
image of Michelle kind of peering out of
one of the school's Windows like in the
background so you're kind of led to
believe like you know has Michelle
perhaps like returned from the grave
like which is a ghost or a Revenant or
something like that
um in order to take revenge on the women
that killed him or is there something
even more Insidious going on now I feel
like the plot twist of diabolique will
probably be familiar to most people
nowadays uh as it's quite famous and it
has been done several times in other
movies since then but even knowing the
twist ahead of time it doesn't really do
anything to diminish the movies like
suspense or like the spooky power that
it has I mean also in the iconic scene
too like toward the end that always gets
shown on those like scariest movie
scenes uh videos that you see on YouTube
and that Bravo did and stuff like that
that scene is still fantastic and really
really effective this many decades later
and I have to say too that like the
entire outcome of the movie like How It
Ends is just so deliciously cruel that
it's really really hard not to love it
it's also really hard to overstate how
influential this movie was on the
suspense genre in particular I mean I
already mentioned how it influenced
psycho but it was also like a big
acknowledged precursor to Michael
Powell's peeping Tom which also came out
in 1960 and was a big influence on Roman
polanski's early films as well
particularly like knife in the water and
some of his other like early films from
the 60s interestingly the movie does a
gender swap on one of the main
characters from The Source novel like in
the book The intended murder victim like
the the one they're trying to kill is
the wife not the husband and also the
movie adds that whole boarding school
setting because that wasn't in the book
either and the book look it's kind of I
feel like the motive was more like we're
gonna get the life insurance payout and
they don't really do that in the movie I
think because the director thought that
that was like kind of a boring angle so
he wanted like a more interesting motive
uh the end of the novel is also somewhat
darker than the ending of the film I
mean the film ending is pretty dark like
don't get me wrong but uh in the book
like the villain basically kind of like
gets away whereas that's not exactly how
it goes down in the movie also as an
amusing footnote I found this very funny
diabolique may have been one of the
first if not the first movie to feature
what's essentially like an anti-spoiler
message like at the end of the movie and
basically it's admonishing viewers like
if you sat through the whole movie
they're like please don't ruin the twist
for your friends that haven't seen it
yet like in case they want to see it so
you know don't be an [ __ ] pretty much
uh and I thought that was very funny
that might very well be the first movie
that did that
um and more famously probably a similar
warning would appear in Alfred
Hitchcock's psycho which came out five
years after this so it might have been
again like very influential in that
regard it's very very tense it's
beautifully shot it's really really
wonderfully acted and I feel like it's
one of those Classics that still holds
up to this day like at least in my
opinion uh so anybody at all that has
any you know if you like Hitchcock
movies if you like suspense movies in
general or if you just like are into
horror movies and want to see like where
some of the tropes came from like if you
know if you're into film history in that
sense then this is definitely one that
you absolutely need to see it's kind of
like required viewing I feel like for
horror and suspense fans so if you
haven't seen it you probably should get
around to it and uh if you have seen it
let me know what you thought about it
also let me know if you've seen the 1996
remake which I think I did see but I
remember it not being all that great
although I haven't seen it uh recently
but let me know what you thought of that
if you saw that as well so you know
we'll have a discussion about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
installment of flickers of fear I will
see see you guys again on the next one
bye